die fed definierung auf sf mit di so
swiss re rb
[Musik]
die welt wandelt sich auch jene der
winzer für manche schweizer weinbauern
steht die zukunft auf dem spiel
in genf wo da mir mehr nur gegen den rat
seines vaters ins geschäft einsteigen
will
er sagte mir ganz klar mach was anderes
wer das mit leidenschaft macht opfer
gleich sein ganzes leben dafür
[Musik]
im loro piana schon dem betrieb seinen
sohn brasil übergeben hat es ist genauso
haltung mit seinen kindern zu arbeiten
die mit seinen vater jetzt habe ich das
sagen aber sicher müssen wir wachsen
[Musik]
im tessin oder das riesige weingut
tamburini nach generationen der
männerherrschaft nun von dieser jungen
frau valentina geleitet wird
als frau hat man es in diesem metier
nicht leicht es ist nach wie vor eine
männerdomäne
[Musik]
in graubünden wo ihren grünen felder
gegen den willen ihrer kinder das bio
zertifikat anstrengt
schwachsinn
auf dem weg hoch zum weingut denke ich
mir immer wunderschön da war stark
gefährdet
und im wallis wo marion brasch mit aller
kraft eines der vorzeige güte führt
sie ist die seele des weinguts begonnen
[Musik]
die winzerinnen der berggipfel die einen
nachfolger sucht
für diese fünf winzerinnen und winzer
ist der jahresverlauf voller
ungewissheit vier jahreszeiten
gut wir sind fast vollzählig schön habt
ihr euch alle bedient kaffee und so alle
soweit zufrieden wir hatten nicht gerade
ein einfaches jahr aber die trauben sind
jetzt wirklich toll
das dachte ich schon gestern als ich
durch die anlage spazierte wir nehmen
uns alle roten trauben vor den ganzen
pinot noir
das wird ein voller tag dann gibt's noch
ein paar kleinigkeiten zu erledigen
wie es danach weitergeht weiß ich noch
nicht so genau heute am vorabend der
lese sollten wir diesen wunderbaren
moment wirklich genießen und so ist auch
jeder erntetag eigentlich ein fest
[Musik]
das ist ja wie eine schulreise ernte
2018 erster tag im jahr übernimmt das
kommando und luc fährt mit zu den
anlagen passt auf die finger auf
vater league übernimmt vor ort das oder
[Musik]
er verteilt euch hier links und rechts
und wir nehmen uns mal diese drei reihen
vor sind es nur drei
ja aber die gehen immerhin bis dort
runter wenn wir rechtzeitig fertig
werden wird uns der chef sicher noch das
eine oder andere zu tun geben als grünen
und abschluss dann lassen wir uns zeit
ich mach dann die vierte gemäss lück ist
damian der chef
und doch müssen sich vater und sohn
absprechen was nicht ganz ohne
spannungen geht
[Musik]
in bildung greifen david und gerne ihrer
großmutter marion tatkräftig unter die
arme
hast du gesehen da ist noch der ganze
riesling sein erster erntetag in einem
der steilsten rippberger des weinguts
das sind kästen wunderbar da gibt es
keine ausreden na dann los geht's zu
zweit geht schneller
ich freue mich unglaublich die ernte
machen zu können gesund zu sein
ich habe mir gesagt es ist eine freude
das muss ich in vollen zügen genießen
ich schneide unheimlich gerne trauben ab
die herausforderung besteht darin bis
zum schluss gesund zu bleiben ohne
fehltritte
denn seit jackie stewart roth die
gesamte verantwortung auf ihren
schultern
mach dich das nicht einfach glücklich im
winter kannst du hier mal mit dem
schlitten runterfahren und dann wieder
rauf klettern
die reihen wieder hoch steigen die
trauben nach oben tragen in beton wird
am steilhang geerntet manche nennen es
auch extrem ernten
[Musik]
david da bist du
ist der weg das gegengewicht ja
[Musik]
in graubünden kann ihre hin auf eine
treue truppe von hilfskräften zählen die
mit den arbeitsbedingungen vertraut sind
in jenes zählt jede traube also zog der
user dann hätten die erntehelfer sind
instruiert da sie jetzt das bio siegel
hat möchte sie eine vorbildliche lese
vorzeigen können wir schaffen zu suchen
also in einer sehr große straße den
erhöhten zumal wenn sie sind wild ganze
so ganz lampe die familie ist zur
unterstützung gekommen
einschließlich tochter europa und
natürlich auch sohn johannes der eines
tages den betrieb übernehmen wird gern
und gut aussehen und das ist eigentlich
in riva hat die lese bereits in der
august begonnen
das gab es vorher noch nie diese drei
hektaren sind die gebündelte arbeit
eines ganzen jahres nach der dürre ist
es nun an der zeit bilanz zu ziehen
die ernte ist immer auch mit stress
verbunden
die trauben kommen in den keller da
steckt eine ganze geschichte dahinter
einflüsse des klimas der witterungs
wechselt da ist einiges passiert meiner
ansicht nach gehört das erzählen dieser
geschichte auch zur rolle einer kleinen
winzerei kellerei wie wir sind
und klar ist die ernte stressig denn das
ist der moment in dem man als winzer
geschichte schreibt festhält was sich
die ganze saison über ereignet hat
erster eintrag dass ernte gewicht
es ist die hälfte der ernte und die
zahlen fallen nicht wie erhofft aus als
basel die leitung des betriebs übernahm
entschied er auf herbizide zu verzichten
und dieses jahr mit diesen überaus
trockenen bedingungen haben die reden
anlagen gelitten
deshalb werden wir keine
durchschnittliche ernte erzielen
wir haben weniger liter das jahr 2018
war wirklich sehr schwierig dafür
bezahlten nun den preis
[Musik]
auf qualität setzen und dabei seine
entscheidung für bio anbau in die
waagschale werfen wird sich basels
strategie dieses jahr bezahlt machen
bei tamburini findet die leser auf
industrielle weise statt ohne ihren
vater übernimmt valentina hat die
beaufsichtigung dutzende von arbeitern
durchkämmen die 70 hektar ich habe diese
arbeit auch gemacht ich weiß was das
bedeutet als ich abends nach hause kam
konnte ich mich fast nicht mehr bewegen
um diese große logistische
herausforderung zu meistern verlässt
sich valentina auf die unterstützung von
pr ihrem chef ökonomen in der woche also
am sonntag werden wir wohl 85 prozent
der trauben geerntet haben
somit bleiben uns noch 15 prozent der
reben für nächste woche das ist der
mellow yellow ist nun mal so lieber lose
als zu kompakt vor allem auch wegen der
vollen es eine gute süße und die kerne
sind schon verholzt ich denke wir sind
etwa bei 92 oechsle
hohe zucker alkohol und konzentrations
werte das markenzeichen dieses sonnigen
jahrgangs im tessin wie überall in der
schweiz dieses jahr haben wir ein sehr
großes potenzial denn unsere winzer
haben hervorragende arbeit geleistet die
trauben sind von guter gesundheit und
qualität
daher gibt es nicht viel auszusortieren
man muss sich nur anschauen ich
betrachte sie bewundere sie ich nehme
mir zeit
heute mag ich nichts über allen ich will
diesen moment genießen
ich kann dabei meine batterien aufladen
ich arbeite viel lieber in der freien
natur als im büro
das macht mich auf dauer wahnsinnig und
es macht den kopf müde
hierbei wird man vielleicht körperlich
etwas müde es ist sehr warm man schwitzt
aber es bereitet unglaublich viel freude
[Musik]
in genf vergehen die tage damian
beaufsichtigt die lese wo ist papa dort
drüben blätter geratete trautmann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
vater lück ist immer dabei und kümmert
sich um die tauben dem meine freunde zu
nerven habe ich immer gesagt dass ich
mit 60 in rente gehen würde
das was meine frau und ich aufgebaut
habe nach meinem vater und meinem onkel
meinen großeltern mütterlicherseits ist
bei damme ja in guten händen
es ist unglaublich so eine menge zu
haben wenn man die trauben an fast merkt
man wie prall sie sind das spürt man
geht auch nichts daneben 1 er steht mir
immer mit seiner erfahrung und guten
ratschlägen zur seite
ich hoffe dass er noch lange dabei sein
wird die leser auch noch genießen kann
mit etwas abstand vielleicht um nicht im
ganzen stress ausgesetzt zu sein
[Musik]
kupplung kaputt
mist ich schieb dich an
sonst machen wir den rest also und du
schiebst einfach klar so machen wir es
auskuppeln moment ich muss mal schauen
mist ist ein hebel abgebrochen dass er
mit allen die man nicht vorhersehen kann
[Applaus]
es ist die kupplung steuerung und da
muss eine lösung finden und zwar schnell
ohne traktor kann die ernte nicht zum
keller transportiert werden es ist sehr
warm daher muss zwingend verhindert
werden dass die trauben noch vor ort zu
gären beginnen in der ganzen schweiz
findet die ernte unter für den monat
september tropischen bedingungen statt
wie schützt man die trauben vor
temperaturen über 30 grad in bildung
vertraut maria auf ein system das chucky
erfunden hat das ist wasser aus beton
und das hier ist ja cool und system das
fließt dann von hier direkt durch die
pipeline
das ganze ist sehr empfindlich man muss
unheimlich aufpassen
jemand muss oben stehen und jemand unten
und man muss sicher sein dass es
wirklich bis ganz runter fließt
denn ist er muss den ball einmal
gepresst muss er runter ins tal auf
einer höhe von 800 metern ohne jegliche
zufahrtswege musste eine erfindung er
die ihren ursprung bei den alt betrieben
hat
[Applaus]
v
[Musik]
die weißweine werden hier gepresst und
fließen durch die pipeline runter die
schack 1971 erfunden hat das muss
langsam durch fließen damit der schlauch
nicht zu voll wird sonst läuft es über
[Musik]
die lese den steilhang runter fließen
lassen
durch diese leitung mit einem
durchmesser von 5 cm 450 meter weiter
unten werther traubenmost gesammelt und
schnell bevor die gärung einsetzt so
pierre antoine gebracht er ist der
önologe der für die weinherstellung
zuständig ist
[Musik]
das ist genau eine zwischen größer das
wirst du wieder anschweißen müssen ja
erst biegen wir den zurecht und dann
reparieren wir dazu noch heute fertig zu
werden
wenn das hier hält dann ist gut
was meinst du wenn wir mal ein kumpel
[Musik]
ok dann kann man direkt zu den reden und
ich hole die anderen
die erntearbeit kann fortgesetzt werden
aber auf dauer kommt schon das nächste
problem zu
[Musik]
das etikett in der handfläche bitte
wieso soll man es verstecken
nein kennst du die geschichte mit dem
etikett in der handfläche liegt du bist
doch sonne lee du bist vielleicht
erwähnt serverlast meinem beruf mehr
dann alle den wein mit dem etikett nach
oben in die hand nehmen bildet sich der
satz immer auf dieser seite
[Musik]
in riva kommt es zwischen vater und sohn
ebenfalls zu diskussionen als sohn
brasil den betrieb übernahm beschluss pr
sich zurückzuziehen
es ist nicht immer leicht dabei zu
bleiben vor allem nicht während des
ernte stresses das hier wurde bereits
gekeltert ich habe heute morgen die
hilfe beigemischt das da wird morgen
früh gekeltert und adress da kommt
hierher
er ist auf dem weinkeller ich kann ihm
in sachen druckverhältnisse mengen
gewicht und so weiter vollends vertrauen
und falls man eingreifen muss tut er das
auch er kann gar nicht anders und das
ist auch richtig so
als er noch der chef war kann noch seine
meinung jetzt habe eigentlich das sagen
aber sicher gibt es manchmal auch
diskussionen die kühlung ausgeschaltet
hier läuft sie nicht okay früher ließ
sich manchmal die kühlung über nacht
laufen und morgens blieb alles zu lange
kalt und die gärung konnte nicht
einsetzen das ist dann eine katastrophe
daher ist sie hier aus ich hab das
jeweils aufgewärmt das machen wir hier
nicht aber so wird es nicht aus versehen
zu kalt aber man kann's aufwärmen wenn
du willst nein das ist nicht nötig
[Musik]
in jenes sind alle rotweine unter dach
und fach
johannes unterstützt ihren tatkräftig
die tauben sind verkehrt und so kann nun
das abmessen beginnen
er ist wie ich 2008 sind nach dem abt
pressen kommt die erste degustation das
neue produkt probieren die früchte der
arbeit eines ganzen jahres kosten ihren
teil diesen wertvollen moment mit ihrem
sohn
also ich zweite haben es wirklich im
keller wirtschaft und dem grundsatz
haben den haben wir erkennen dass er
jeden ablaufen jeder handgriff
ich glaube man hätte das für den gezogen
also ich bin zu stellen das sind immer
ganz einfache antwort wenn das sich
nimmt enorm viel größer wenn man halt
immer nach zweitem einig und zwar nicht
irgendeines sondern qualifizierte
meinung und das ist schon sehr wertvoll
das ist johanniter würdig sein
johanniter in einem inox gehälter als
ich 16 war konnte ich noch nicht
wirklich degustieren klar ich kannte den
wein aber es interessierte mich nicht so
er ist sehr aromatisch zumindest im mund
der ist erst im kommen stimmt er hat
eine unglaubliche süße mein vater hat
mir diese leidenschaft vermittelt eine
schöne säure auf jeden fall hier in
diesen fässern lagert mein baby dann
wollte ich noch zwei weitere weine
kreieren einen roten und einen weißen
divine familie valentina wein collection
wird ein eigenes logo haben
darauf wird ein phönix abgebildet seien
ein symbol für mein leben aus der asche
auferstehen immer wer das gerade trifft
sich valentina zwei stockwerke weiter
oben mit den grafikern sie legen ihr
einen ersten entwurf vor wir haben zwei
entwürfe für ein label
dabei sind wir seinem wunsch folgend von
einem phönix ausgegangen
ich bin ergriffen
zum konzept wir wollten mit flügeln
arbeiten die auch das element der sonne
aufgreifen weil du eine strahlende
starke junge frau voller energie bist
das heißt ganz klar weidlich aber stark
dieses logo stellt genau das dar
valentina ist sprachlos
damian seinerseits scheint ebenfalls
entschlossen seinen eigenen weg zu gehen
während der ernte ist es zu
auseinandersetzungen gekommen
ich habe möglicherweise etwas gesagt
dass ihm nicht gepasst hat und nun ist
er weg wir sprechen nicht mehr
miteinander können wir die ali g t au
auf brauchen auch nicht
da möchte dir doch verkaufen
das ist immer noch mein haus also kann
ich das entscheiden es geht nicht darum
was er alles für mich für uns getan hat
dafür bin ich ihm unglaublich dankbar
aber unsere beziehung war doch auch
schwierig vielleicht musste es ja so
kommen damit er wirklich ganz aufhört
mit einem paukenschlag
hallo meine kleine schau
die trauben sind hier drin mit der
großen maschine haben wir den saft
ausgepresst und darf ich da raus
und wohin er wollte eine saubere
trennung und ich konnte das nicht
verstehen
bei meinem vater und mir war das damals
anders
heute verstehe ich dass ich mich
aufgedrängt habe ich habe mich mit
meinem vater mehr gestrichen das mit
meinem sohn
aber das gehört wohl dazu bei den mehr
muss sind laut starke diskussion teil
des erbes
[Musik]
es ist normal dass dieser übergang
stattfindet
[Musik]
hier bringt
in riva hat brasil immer noch alle hände
voll zu tun
während pr die traditionen aufrecht
erhält wie immer werden mein bruder jean
marc und ich euch ein lied vortragen
wir singen für euch der linie des chemie
geschrieben vom bekannten schossen je
und dichter robben der in chelsea vor
armut
[Musik]
villmar
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in bildung herrscht noch keine fest
stimmen
im gegenteil
[Musik]
ich wollte nur etwas holen nun schon bin
ich von der leiter gefallen
das ist das letzte woran ich mich
erinnere
der ellbogen war ausgerenkt und sie
stellten fest dass meine nase irgendwie
gebrochen war und ich habe das bis heute
noch nicht verstanden aber irgendwas mit
der augenhöhle
da war etwas gebrochen und es hat
geblutet das mussten sie beobachten und
an der wange musste etwas gefällt werden
[Musik]
für marion gibt es keine pause
sie hat die arbeit wieder aufgenommen
unterstützt wird sie von ihren töchtern
das ende der ernte naht aber die
unsicherheit bleibt
dre das mal ich schaffe es nicht du
musst fest drücken natürlich stellen
sich fragen ob mit oder ohne diesen
unfall die frage der nachfolge stellt
sich so oder so was sollen wir tun
wir haben ein paar ideen aber kann man
die auch alle umsetzen es ist schwierig
das abzuschaffen
willst du glöckchen nein danke ich habe
schon genug auf dem teller
[Musik]
auf den abschluss der lese anstoßen
die essenz von einem jahr arbeit kosten
überall in der schweiz wird das ende der
ernte gefeiert zeit bilanz zu ziehen und
in gewissen betrieben die zukunft
auszuloten
dieses jahr hatte ich wahnsinnig viel
arbeit
ich wollte auch ganz viele dinge angehen
und so habe ich mir selber noch mehr
arbeit gemacht und so geht's voran mit
der valentina wein collection und vivi
2017 war ein erfolg wie immer trifft
valentinas vater erst nach der ganzen
aufregung ein
zurück aus dem urlaub voller worte des
lobes ich muss zuallererst die winzer
wünschen
er steht an vorderster front die ernte
war gut gesund und spannend die lese war
auch perfekt organisiert gesunde schöne
trauben so wie es sich gehört
danke danke
[Applaus]
mein vater hat mich immer unterstützt
er sagte immer versuchs und wenn du hin
fällt dann steh einfach wieder auf dafür
bin ich ihm heute dankbar das hat mich
stark gemacht
carola glückwunsch auf das ende der
ernte auf den wein auf den wein auf uns
auf tamburin
ich wünsche mir dass mein betrieb sich
weiterentwickelt und eines tages möchte
ich auch eine familie gründen
denn die familie ist quelle der freude
der gelassenheit
[Musik]
denn jenes liegt die zukunft in den
händen von mutter und sohn johannes hat
er bereits klare vorstellungen großes
mit 20 hektar lively vitali alles selber
schaffen und auch der überblick jahres
und mit meiner mutter daisy wurde glüht
delegiert sondern auch mitgliedschaft
und sich denkt unterschätzen dass man
wenn man mal verschüttet wie schmeckt
werden menschen 22
ich habe mir gesprochen aber konkrete
man also im moment das muss erstmal
nicht wenn wir einmal alle wieviel
sorgte das wetter neues konzept machen
wir abladen und alles ist es sehr still
halten den hörer geschichte mal neu
aufgleisen und morgen die serie und dann
jährigen das rennen werden
also es gab mindestens noch drei auf
[Musik]
bei johannes ist erst mal geduld
angesagt sein wekwerth ihnen über
neuseeland und viele zukünftige
erfahrungen führen bevor er dann eines
tages den familienbetrieb übernimmt
in riva wird das ende der erntezeit mit
einer allerletzten lese gefeiert die
ganze gruppe zieht los um die trauben
von den steilsten weinterrassen des
lavaux einzusammeln
am sagenumwobenen
[Musik]
hier für dich zum wohl der ist ja
hervorragend ist sehr gut da gibt mir
mut danke
[Musik]
zurück im keller prüft basel die früchte
von einem jahr arbeit
er hatte auf qualität gesetzt
eine solche qualität vorzufinden ist
senden
das hatten wir 2015 aber das hier
einfach unglaublich das wird ein toller
jahrgang
die wir haben etwas zu wenig vom
weißwein daher haben wir gerade noch
trauben aus riva dazu gekauft so
vervollständigen wir unsere eigene ernte
beim rotwein hingegen haben wir eine
schöne lese dieses jahr
er ist körperlich süß konzentriert dass
in der aromen vorhanden da haben wir
etwas womit wir arbeiten können das uns
freude bereitet und das ist einfach toll
die rotweine werden prächtig damit kann
man arbeiten das freue mich wirklich
fantastisch ich denke so ein jahr erlebt
man nur einmal im leben
[Musik]
basels einsatz hat sich ausgezahlt
zuschauer
für das jahr endet die ernte im keller
[Musik]
ist die alkoholische gärung fast
abgeschlossen
er kommt zudem noch in die fässer der
wird wunderbar wir wollen aber keine zu
starke holz note daher nehmen wir dafür
ziemlich alte zehnjährige fässer dann
wird der wein in einen tank umgefüllt
und kommt anschließend direkt in die
flaschen
in sehr zufrieden mit der arbeit bisher
nichts ist schief gelaufen
die gws entwickeln sich alle ziemlich
gut wir hatten keine probleme mit der
reduktion haben auch keine misslungenen
beine keine fehler unsererseits
dabei greift nun von selbst da muss ich
nichts mehr zu tun
alles ist auf gutem weg
ein solches jahr ist keineswegs ein
selbstläufer vielmehr zeigt es welchen
wert der bio ansatz hat und dass es
möglich ist so zu arbeiten
das gibt uns auch etwas selbstvertrauen
für das nächste jahr
wir können auf dem was wir dieses jahr
erreicht haben aufbauen
ich sage immer dass die erfahrung im
weinbau die summe aller fehler ist die
man bei vergangenen jahr gängen gemacht
hat da sammeln sich wissen an dass eine
sicherheit für das neue jahr gibt
[Musik]
2018 hat damian die wende geschafft nun
führte den betrieb alleine mit der
eigenen familie an seiner seite
unten im tal trifft sich mario mit
pierre antoine der önologe stellt schon
seit langem die weine bisher ein treuer
helfer von marion und seinerzeit auch
von jackie hallo pia und wann wie geht's
gut und dir gut ich hab da eine kleine
auswahl zur degustation für dich denn es
hat sich doch einiges getan
da bin ich aber neugierig wirklich
spannend das ist also jemand muss im
jahr leben einhauchen
ich hatte das glück dass ich chucky
kennenlernen durfte ich habe ihn sehr
geschätzt
im biodynamischen anbau ist es eher
selten dass jemand seine trauben einem
anderen zur weinherstellung anvertraut
das ehrt mich ist doch einiges an zucker
trennen die erste ehrung ist fast
abgeschlossen dann kommt noch die zweite
ein weicher wein ein hybrid sozusagen
bildung und auch jockey haben wieder im
wallis inspiriert und das muss auch
weitergeführt werden die jungen
generationen haben aber kein interesse
daran und den betrieb zu übernehmen
[Musik]
richtig die verantwortung liegt bei mir
und dann werden wir sehen
sonst suchen wir halt andere leute die
sich dafür interessieren
[Musik]
sie müssen in der lage sein einen
solchen betrieb zu führen
ich will auf keinen fall dass auch nur
ein quadratzentimeter dieses weinguts
wieder chemisch behandelt wird dafür
haben wir zu viel investiert
man schaue sich nur einmal an welches
leben in den böden steckt einfach
wunderbar und wir hatten auch den beweis
dafür
bevor ich sterbe möchte ich erleben wie
das ganze wallis biodynamisch wert
der weinbau prägt die täler in der
ganzen schweiz hinter jedem rietberg
steht eine besonderheit ein charakter
eine wein familie eine große vielfalt an
betrieben und möglichkeiten
[Musik]
die wettgewinne auf sf mit die swiss und
legria